hey you guys it's time once again for
yet another movie retrospective going
back to the 80s this time around not
exactly
a cult film that we're talking about
today because it was kind of like a
really big commercial success and it's
still kind of considered a classic of
the horror genre
this is poltergeist from 1982 yeah you
see this one a million times if you
haven't seen this movie no it's
understandable you know if you're if
you're young you know you're young
person that maybe hadn't seen
poltergeist oh yeah lots of ketchup yeah
poltergeist it'd be kind of like an old
played out movie if you were in your 20s
why would I want to watch anything yeah
we've watched it again recently to do
this review
yeah movies held up it really held in a
way that you know a lot of movies from
the up from the 80s have hold up it held
up pretty good
I think and we've kind of talked about
some of the other ones on the show but I
really do think this one is held up
pretty well the special effects still
look pretty good look pretty good yeah
um you know it's the characters it still
looks pretty good it doesn't look
horribly horribly date no CG it was all
practical effects there's a pretty much
except for like the weird like lighting
effects instead yeah but that's still a
practical effect there wasn't there's no
CG in it yeah and then there's like
there was like one real epic shot where
some kind of a poltergeist light is
coming down the stairways and then just
all these shadows are being cast on the
walls from the railings and the you know
they move from the railings and the
staircase and you can see the thing and
yeah I was wondering it was that man how
they do that back then you know it was
something that I liked I was coming down
on a wire and it was cast in all these
shadows over the room and then they
somehow like superimposed some kind of a
animated graphic over the light source
itself but it looked cool it looked
pretty cool pretty much everything it
does look pretty cool now let's talk a
little bit about this movie came out in
the summer of 1982 and it was actually
supposedly and I'm gonna
a second directed by tobe Hooper who
directed a lot of stuff but is probably
most famous for the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre however the movie was written
and produced by Steven Spielberg yeah
now the thing about it is okay Steven
Spielberg was working on et the
extra-terrestrial at the time and in
fact the two movies came out about a
week or two weeks apart in the summer of
1982 now there was this amazing that you
say that I was there and it doesn't
scene it seemed like there's a big big
gap in between those two movies but I
guess you're right yeah they both came
and like I said I don't remember if I
saw a poltergeist in the theater I may
have I know I saw et in the theater and
it's very possible that we might have
seen poltergeist in the theater too like
a week or two later um but I'm not super
sure I might have seen it later on cable
yeah but yeah so the fact that Steven
Spielberg was working on ET at the same
time that poltergeist was going on there
was something in his contract that said
you know you're not allowed to direct
another movie while you're working on ET
you know that was in that was a real
actual obligation so he apparently was a
fan of Texas Chainsaw Massacre so he
asked Toby Hooper to do it
now over the years there has been a lot
of controversy over whether Steven
Spielberg actually did direct the movie
on the sly and tobe Hooper was kind of
just like they're yeah on the set like
there's there's controversy over how
much contribution that tobe Hooper is
Toto he may have been a figurehead
yeah and like I said there's really no
way of determining because you get some
of the actors saying yeah tobe Hooper
was totally the director you know he
blocked the actors he set up the shots
he did all this other stuff
now everybody did say Steven Spielberg
was you know he was the producer he did
write the [ __ ] and he was on set like
pretty much every day and most of the
decisions had to be run through him as
well as tobe Hooper and he would kind of
like do finalized stuff he did some of
the storyboarding and all that kind of
stuff so you know like I said there's
different actors say different things
and different people that were on the
set say different things it's like
nobody's saying that tobe Hooper didn't
you know kind of direct it because he
did he was there every day and he did
like directorial things they just don't
you know no one's really an agreement
over how much control Steven Spielberg
had over the way the final movie turned
out it could be that because things had
to be to Spielberg standard and he was
the guy that would say what would go
what wouldn't go it does seem that when
Han Khanna influencing to edit that what
you end up with is a Steven Spielberg
movie it is but yeah cuz you watch it
and you and it just feels so much like
Spielberg just every aspect
I mean he did write it yeah so there is
that now I do feel like tobe Hooper's
influence can be felt particularly in
the you know the horror of more horror
type elements like you know the corpses
in the pool and the guys face off and
all that I mean that's all Hooper I mean
he may have had that aspect of the input
and it should be noted too that the
initial idea for this movie that Steven
Spielberg came up with it was supposed
to be sci-fi it was supposed to be kind
of like like a more horror oriented
sequel to Close Encounters yeah they're
kind it was supposed to be called dark
skies
now when tobe Hooper came on to direct
it he's like I don't really want to do a
sci-fi movie can we do a ghost story or
like a horror story you know that's more
like a ghost story instead and so Steven
Spielberg said okay we can do that so
Hooper did have that much control over
what you could take e.t Close Encounters
of the Third Kind and poltergeist and
put them all right there in that same
package it's that same tone yeah you
know and it does have a mom apple pie
and Chevrolet all-american feel to it
yeah that's the way America felt when we
were kids yeah it doesn't really feel
that way now it's hard to recapture that
time I don't know if it was just the
aesthetic of the of the furniture and
the music and the way upper middle class
neighborhoods looked at that time yeah
architecture I don't know
although didn't we say that we saw a
movie recently in the way it was shot
the neighborhood shot yeah we saw that
Godzilla movie yeah and the way they
shocked that Japanese
the 2014 mm the way they shot that
Japanese upper middle class neighborhood
with the with the little than the
Japanese houses with the gardens out in
front of it look just like something out
of ET or close encounter Spielberg in so
it may have something to the way the
camera moves and the way the the way the
the the soundtrack in the back is the
score I don't know there's something
about it you can get that old-school
kana American middle class
Spielberg tone if you know what I'm
talking about yeah I mean I well like I
said I do fit well that was why the
whole controversy erupted after the
movie came out because they said that
feels like a Spielberg yeah because you
know Spielberg was very big on these
kind of upper-middle class nuclear
family techniques that were immediately
if not necessarily relatable at least
they were immediately likable you know
you could kind of see where they were
coming from like yeah they were very
invested in them you know immediately
they were you know like I said they
there were very likeable characters you
know and so when they were put in peril
you would feel for them yeah my family
you know my mother had been divorced at
this time so I was in the single parent
single mom situation yeah but still when
I saw those movies I saw the American
upper middle class family nuclear family
you're talking about and to me that was
normal yeah well do a lot of P of our
whole generation yeah even though I
wasn't in that situation I didn't
realize I wasn't I didn't realize I
wasn't in that situation yeah it's weird
so I think everyone could relate to it
yeah it's weird because even though yeah
like me and most people I knew were not
in that yeah Emily situation in a way
like you saw it in a Spielberg movie and
you're like yeah that's supposed to be
it that's kind of like his greatest
talent I think is like kind of taking
this very specific type of family
structure this very specific type of
like class structure and making it
relatable to everyone pretty much you
know and like I said making it to do a
thing where it's like able and you're
just like really into these characters
yeah so
you know if you haven't seen poltergeist
which what the [ __ ] everybody holder
guys this was actually filmed in a real
neighborhood in Simi Valley California
and it's uh in the movie it's supposedly
this new like development called cuesta
Verde and the guy what are the Freeling
family yeah and they have I don't know
how long they've been living in this
house it doesn't seem like they've been
living in it all that long but the dad
you know he works for the real estate
development company that kind of did and
everything like that now like I said we
don't know how long this family has been
living here yeah but pretty much only a
few scenes into the movie crazy [ __ ]
starts to happen in that yes oh you know
what's up very quickly much more quickly
than I remembered
I remember what it was I was trying to
remember there was a movie that
recaptured that feeling was bumblebee
and that was another one now yeah yeah
that Spielberg was involved in yeah I
think yeah I think it was a had a
producer credit on that yeah that that
eighties middle class home structure was
right there and bumblebee and I was like
uh I was like one of the like an old
Spielberg play well like I said they a
lot of those have been coming Ally but
I'm probably because of the huge success
of stranger things which looks very much
like a Steven Spielberg you know like a
dark et Goonies yeah I think I think
also I think America you know overall
kind of yearns back for those days to
the there was a certain amount of
security in that imagery even if you
weren't involved in that yeah you know
there's something about seeing a movie
with that in it well I think you it was
kind of like how generations before us
like look back to the 50s like yeah like
if it was this maybe like an idyllic
time pa like the little house with the
witch it was fun it was fun it was fun
we were there yeah it wasn't perfect but
it was it wasn't fun I mean you know
what I mean but couldn't get anything
cool no cool no cool computers no
internet but yeah so like I said I see
this I had seen this movie like 40
bajillion times when I was growing up
and I hadn't seen it for quite a long
time but I remembered it you know I've
seen it on and off like over the
years now we watched it again because I
think did Netflix just added it or
something Netflix or shudder just added
it so we just said shudder yes so we
what we're plugging the [ __ ] out of
sugar shuddered he's a pastor so we
watched it again the other day and I
remembered most of it there were some of
it I hadn't remembered and one thing
that I hadn't remembered was how quickly
like [ __ ] starts to go south right it's
like like I said this family's living in
this house nothing weird has had a
little there's a little blonde Moffet
like Carolyn and her little birdie dies
and they have a little birdie funeral
and she's super cute and everything like
that and then basically a couple hours
later like in real time you know she's
talking to the TV yeah you know the
chairs in the kitchen are rearranged
yeah
like the [ __ ] silverware is like the
right thing like [ __ ] uri geller is
in the [ __ ] yeah they kind of took
phenomenon from all across all
paranormal reports and tried to put it
all in one case I mean yeah extra mental
stuff uri geller spoon bending and fork
bending yeah I actually have have seen
real poltergeist and really only the the
scene with the chairs being rearranged
actually struck me is like yeah that's
what it's like that's freak to be the
fun yeah I was a kid but even more than
the other [ __ ] I mean some of the other
scenes were scary too like especially
when I was a kid but you know especially
with a clown and everything everybody
talks about the clown scene but for some
reason just that scene where Carolyn's
just sitting there in the kitchen and
her mom like bends down to get some [ __ ]
out of the cabinet and all of a sudden
she Chung like all the chairs are like
stacked all over that freaks me the [ __ ]
yeah the whole thing with the toys
flying in the in you know flying around
through the air and they it's it wasn't
like that boy when the cook doors were
shut it would make you think that that
was going on in there but no no the only
baby it would have been if you could
have opened I don't the only thing that
really Connor reminded me of mammoth
mountain poltergeist was you know you
turn your back on something turnaround
is different like the chair scene yeah
you might see something thrown at you
from a direction where you weren't
looking at
there was nobody there to throw it but
you know like that but one of the things
I liked about this is that you know at
first like most people probably would I
mean this is a very this couple you know
Stephen and Diane Freeling the mom and
dad they seem like kind of laid-back
sort of yo they used to be hippies and
[ __ ] you know there's smoke a pot and
everything like it like that in their
room so poltergeist [ __ ] starts
happening in the house it doesn't seem
dangerous like it's kind of creepy and
stuff like that so initially the mom she
just thinks it's kind of neat so she's
home one day and she's like putting
caroline on the floor and Carolyn's
getting pulled across by some force or
some [ __ ] like that she puts a little
helmet on her and everything and she's
like what her husband comes home she's
like check this [ __ ] out it's so awesome
and I never went to that don't mean
Louis cut that's what I mean that's what
I liked about we thought it was neat
during the day but we need our yeah in a
night and no we didn't like it yeah yeah
I mean like I was watching you yeah I
liked that they had that aspect of it
where if that [ __ ] like if the chairs
rearranged it's like you probably [ __ ]
your pants but then you'd be like let's
see if it was it again for you see if it
does again you tried to figure it out
here we're trying to figure it out and
that's exactly what she did like her and
her daughter they were like figure out
what's going on so at first they just
thought it was kind of neat but then I
think it was like that night like a
couple hours later like after the whole
chair incident when they still thought
it was neat and then the kid Robbie gets
sucked out of the window by the evil
tree and trees like gotta eat them if
you asked me the whole chair thing and
trying to figure it out you know we live
that life and that checks out with us I
think what happened was the Spielberg
read this house is haunted by guy and I
and play you might have
that's the Enfield case because that's
what Nora would happen objects move and
you try to figure out what is this yeah
you try to debunk it to yourself you
know I've heard you know I heard that
one of the poltergeist cases that
actually was the inspiration for this
was actually popper the poltergeist in
Long Island okay before Amityville I
haven't didn't like the 60s or the 70s I
can't remember when but if there was a
lot of [ __ ] going on in that but the the
most common manifestation was like
bottles would like their caps
Popoff right and like [ __ ] would come
flying out of the bottles like all
different kind of bottles around the
house and um I I think that was kind of
one of the inspirations for this also
cuz that was kind of a really big famous
case at the time even though it was kind
of forgotten after that all the
Amityville [ __ ] happens in the same
place but yes so you know as cool as it
was the first day with the chairs and
everything then suddenly Robbie gets
eaten by a tree and then Caroline gets
sucked into the TV or sucked into the
closet or whatever by the you know
whatever it is that's haunting this
house they do call this hat they do call
this poltergeist even though it ends up
being ghost
yeah haunting I mean it ends up being at
first it seems very poltergeist II but
yeah in case if you're not a regular
listener we've done many shows in the
past and she's written books on it there
is a difference in haunting phenomenon
and poltergeist phenomena there is some
crossover in some cases but they're two
very different phenomena yeah yeah so
like I said and now the first thing they
do and this kind of cracks me up to like
you know bad [ __ ] happens Carol Ann gets
sucked into the closet or into the other
dimension or whatever they call some
parapsychologists to come there and by
the time the parapsychologists get there
the the phenomena has become so blase
that the family are just kind of like I
love that scene where they're all
sitting around the table with the pair
of psychologists and then like the
[ __ ] coffee pot or whatever like
slides across the table by itself and
the family is just like man whatever
yeah and then like the light goes in
there the guys like trying to take a
picture she's like oh we got to be
quicker than that or anything you know I
mean they're just like so maybe like no
it's gonna do it again yeah they're just
like so laissez-faire about like
whatever it's just doing it all the time
now and meanwhile the pair of
psychologists are like flipping the [ __ ]
out
so they come there and I think that the
parapsychologist being there this was
like my favorite scene and when I was
really little like you know when I was
like 11 years old and I was watching
this movie the scene where the one
parapsychologist guy like tears his own
face off
yeah that really bother it was just a
hallucination
he'd imagined that yeah it really didn't
really but I mean the whole sequence
where you know he's getting he's
evidently I guess they said hey take
whatever you want in the fridge and he's
like chewing I'm going in there score so
he goes in there he's got like a chicken
leg in his mouth and he's like hey I'm
gonna cook the steak I'm gonna do the
other and then the steak like starts
like scooting across the [ __ ] kitchen
counter and they're like spewing crap
everywhere that it's got maggots on it
you know the chicken has maggots on it
then he's like hey I'm gonna go in the
bathroom and start tearing terrible gaw
bits of flesh off my face I didn't see
this in a theater I saw I think an HBO
after we had better I think I did too
and it was so it's probably like yeah
and this was after I'd had my own
experience I mean there were parts the
movies just in the beginning that I was
like yeah man that's what I that's what
I saw but then as it ramped up it got
more and more you know Hollywood you
know I mean it's not that [ __ ]
intense you know I mean and then it some
of the [ __ ] that it did was just you
know something you'd see from like a
Lorraine Warren case but it was still a
good movie you know it is it's not
terribly believable but a lot of yeah
it's entertainment but I have to say
yeah and now here's another thing that I
hadn't remembered from you know the last
time I saw this movie which was probably
many years ago till we just watched it
like the other day I remembered the very
famous scene of the [ __ ] clown doll
which why the hell would you give that
to your children I mean come on that's
like nightmare you wouldn't write there
you wouldn't give it a life-size clown
doll it's like hey I'm gonna sit this
right at the end of your bed so it
stares at you asleep you know what I
mean so it's sitting there and then
Robbie's like looking at it going [ __ ]
this [ __ ] I can't go to sleep without it
he tries to throw the blanket over it
and [ __ ] and then like he tries to go to
sleep and then he looks back at the
clown is gone and then he was like
looking under the thing and that it
comes up behind I'm like like you know
and it scared the [ __ ] one of the best
jump scares in horror history and that
thing that was awesome was his toys I'm
looking at his toys and man I had that
yeah you know I mean that the Darth
Vader - action figure carry it saw where
you put on the airs in it yeah and the
Empire Strikes Back little medical droid
with all little arms and the
in the Han Solo Hoth edition yeah at all
the cool [ __ ] yeah I had the Han Solo
yeah I had all this it had we had we had
the HOF playset and we had it came with
a little Han Solo with the blue coat and
the little tauntaun yeah and the little
tauntauns little belly opened I had so
much that [ __ ] I had like I had like
eight of the stormtroopers in like five
or six of it the Death Star guys yeah
yeah and then like everything else I had
almost all them for a while my favorite
was the Imperial Guards like this little
red guys I didn't have this yeah I like
this it's like there their heads are
plastic I mean they were all plastic
obviously but then they had like a
little cloth cake and they were like by
the time by the time Return of the Jedi
came out I was kind of out of the action
figures hey yeah it was just Star Wars
and Empire Strikes Back I was almost too
old for him by the time returning Jedi
came out yeah look at my like him but
I'd never really bought any of them yeah
but the thing that I hadn't remembered
was that you know after the
parapsychologists like come in there and
be like you know they filmed all this
[ __ ] that happened and they're like okay
well we just proved ghosts like forever
Nobel Prize for uh yeah they didn't say
that but they should have and real life
but you know then they're like we can't
do anything about this we have to call
the spirit medium who's you know tangina
or tan Jon or her we're out there named
Zelda Rubenstein is the actor's name and
she comes in very famously and you know
she is actually a real psychic she can
like reach a thousand [ __ ] yeah and she
thinks she clears the house you know
after Carol Ann gets sucked out and then
you know the mom has to go in through
the closet with the rope and the dad
almost [ __ ] it up because she says
don't pull on the rope and then he pulls
on the rope like a dumbass cuz you can't
listen but but you know what I mean like
the mom and the kid or Fri and they're
all covered with goop and whatever but I
had remembered the clown scene with
Robbie happening like earlier in the
movie but it doesn't happen until after
tangina says the house is clean and
everybody leaves yeah and then the free
Ling's are like okay well even though
the house is supposedly clean we're
still getting the [ __ ] addiction come
back and then they're gonna move and
then like the night before like they're
gonna move like the next day cuz they're
packing up the truck and [ __ ] like that
yeah and then they're just waiting for
the dad to come back from work cuz he's
gonna go to work and tell them you know
[ __ ] you I quit
because you only broke the headstones
you don't mean so but he doesn't say
that so later but um you know I mean so
then he's gone and then Walt the mom and
the two two of the kids are like a home
oh [ __ ] hell breaks loose it's a big
[ __ ] ghost dragon in there that's
like [ __ ] she fall in the pool and
there's bodies there's [ __ ] coffins
you know she's had I know she's had a
lot of vodka when she starts saying
[ __ ] not cooking the seven times in
one sentence what are you it's just I
like it because it provides a nice like
rhythm you know okay but yeah I had four
I had forgotten that there was that
whole you know that there was that whole
thing like after like all the pair of
psychology's in the seconds left and
we're like yeah everything's fine now
and then all of a sudden they're like no
it's not fine I'm like all this crazy
[ __ ] happened and that's when the clown
should happen for some reason I thought
it happened no there was a head towards
the end at that yeah so you saw the
clown in the middle part to build it up
for that for that to happen yeah it was
there was building you up yeah so
another thing and like I told you um I
don't remember if I told you earlier or
not but this movie was originally when
it went to get you know the rating from
the MPAA they originally gave us in our
rating but Steven Spielberg and tobe
Hooper they were like no please can we
please have a PG because they didn't
have a pg-13 rating until two years
later I think it was 84 that they got
the pg-13 rating so they appealed the R
rating because they wanted everybody to
see it
so the MPA were like okay guy gets his
face torn off corpses kid get him by a
tree why not so they made it the P R
rating and the pg-13 rating was stupid
anyway and you can make a badass movie
pg-13 if you know what you're doing yeah
if you know what you're doing you have
to edit just a couple little select
front frames oh yeah it was just kind of
like the recent like the remake of the
the Deadpool that we wanted to see if
they could make it pg-13 and Omega they
are reading from a time in America's
history most of those people are dead
now that wanted that are rating all
right yeah David died of old age
most of it had to do it
yeah that's all I had to do it you can
pretty much show the violence you want
yeah they usually like titties yes
that's yeah which is just ridiculous man
it's like you can show people getting
their heads blown off but show a nipple
and everyone sister they had some kind
of weird religious thing going on back
then they're all gone though I had to
worry about him but yeah so I guess the
pg-13-rated was good because it ended up
just ended up making like a [ __ ] ton of
money over the summer and like I said it
was probably it's considered one of the
best movies in ita2 probably one of the
best horror movies ever made and I would
probably agree with that assessment
now I had forgotten completely but they
made a remake of this [ __ ] like in 2015
they did 2013 this one of poltergeist
yes oh I bet you that was an abomination
and well like I said I didn't even know
until recent ill I was like reading the
Wikipedia page I'm like get the [ __ ] out
of here like I know I I knew that they
made one of a medieval horror which
actually wasn't awful I didn't mind it
um you know it wasn't great that's what
an evil horror wasn't great the original
wasn't all that great so I was just kind
of like alright I'll allow it but I
didn't see the remake of this now I
wouldn't mess with it no I probably
wouldn't even though Sam Rockwell is in
it and I love him but you know I don't
know I'll probably see there are certain
movies that have to be left alone yeah I
don't know if you could really you can't
capture the tone of this again is it
it's so much a product of its time I
don't I know I say that about a lot of
imagine if you tried to remake et I'm
sure they're going to at some point so
um yeah so they actually did make two
sequels to this poltergeist to the other
side which actually wasn't bad yeah um I
I kind of liked a little bit cheesy but
you know I liked the guy that played the
cult leader like Henry Caine he was
super creepy yeah um the third one that
they made was I don't even remember that
one the third one was the one that was
in the Chicago high rise only Carol Ann
was in it it could Heather O'Rourke
could've been good it I didn't like it
um Tom Skerritt was in it and you know I
liked him but it they didn't get this
actor to play Henry Caine because that
guy had passed away cuz he was old as
[ __ ] and it wasn't in the same setting
like it was in a city setting and that
was just I don't know it would you know
it was just the little girl was fine I
you know I loved her but you know what I
mean the the rest of the family wasn't
there the dynamic wasn't there it just
it wasn't the same kind of movie I
remember when poltergeist 2 came out I I
kind of enjoyed it
best watching it on HBO yeah but part
two is all right yeah but you could tell
they were pushing it you know I mean
like this that part too really shouldn't
have happened
yeah you know I mean they were kind of
like [ __ ] with your ability to
suspend disbelief you know talking about
it really shouldn't happen but you
accepted it because it was alright the
thing that I didn't like it was better
is like if you wanted to see poltergeist
again you just to watch life force or
something like that
yeah which is another crazy [ __ ]
movie there's like it bothered me and
maybe I shouldn't complain too much
about this because it is like a [ __ ]
ghost story and you know the the [ __ ]
that they found out about the haunting
in the first poltergeist you know it
came from like mediums of parasite cuz
nobody knows about this [ __ ] you know
what I mean so so if you're writing a
story for the sequel they're like well
it's parapsychology can just make [ __ ]
up because in the first story the whole
thing was that the evil real-estate
developers had torn out this huge
cemetery to make the thing and it's like
yeah we totally moved the cemetery
except for the bodies we just moved the
headstones you know what I made and it's
like yeah which is really implausible
because you can't build anything on top
of a cemetery I mean I'm not gonna hit
something means you can't put it there's
so much empty space y'all yeah like you
really don't need to like just wouldn't
happen that way in real life but it'd
look good on ya but it looked good on
camera and like I said the whole end of
the movie like had all these coffins
popping out alike like that now in the
second movie they came out and said oh
well no really the ghosts were you know
of this Henry Caine guy was like a cult
leader and all his cult followers who
were in a cave like underneath the
cemetery so I get it's like a
double-decker haunting yeah I guess
which
okay fair enough um the third one like I
said was just kind of thing now another
thing that I want to mention about this
that a lot of people have talked about
in regards to poltergeist is that for a
while some people have thought and they
even remember back when they had that
channel II and they had e true Hollywood
story that the production of poltergeist
was supposedly cursed although I'm
sitting there going okay i-i've heard of
the poltergeist curse because yes
Heather O'Rourke died at the age of 12
before the third one came out because
they had to use a body double in the
third one a lot of times he was a cute
little girl did she why she was adorable
she died of actually she had
complications from a bowel obstruction
mm-hmm she died of that also the girl
that played Dana the teenage daughter in
the first movie she was actually
murdered by her boyfriend yeah only a
few months after poltergeist came out
like he strangled her um so I thought
that there was more to it than that like
I thought there was more because you
know how some movies they're like oh
this person died on the set and then
this person like had some crazy you know
and there was more crazy [ __ ] but I
think the whole thing of the curse the
whole thing I could find about the curse
on Wikipedia was just that those two
people yeah the rest was legit two kids
died because I remember during the time
you know back in the 80s but before you
could get your hands on information
because there was no you know there was
no internet I thought the little girl
had died of some kind of weird leukemia
no it was just
complications of a balanced or was a
bowel obstruction she was 12 years old
ouka and um yeah it was weird because in
the third one like I said if you watch
the third one they're all kind of creepy
to watch cuz you know she's dead now
and she didn't really very long um but
the third one she looks ill you know
what I mean and they they actually used
like like I said body doubles for some
of the shots like especially there's
there's one near the end where like the
her aunt and uncle are like holding on
to her and they don't show her face and
you know that that's not really her but
she looked like she had kind of like
blown up a little bit like she was like
kind of weird and like bloated looking
and I don't know if that was like dude
or diseased or anything like that but I
had totally for
and about the the girl playing Dana
getting strangled Meyer was right and
that happened the same year that the
movie came out I think it happened in
like the movie came out in June and I
think she got she died in November of
that year 1982 she was like only 16 or
17 years old and her boyfriend only
served like three [ __ ] years for like
voluntary manslaughter or something like
that no there might have been more to
the story there yeah for Strangler but
yeah so that was the whole thing about
the poltergeist curse but like I said
this is a movie that much like
Ghostbusters which came out two years
later yeah I always associated this
movie with goes there but yeah there are
very similar kind of similarities to
them they this is probably I mean this
is easily one of the best horror movies
of the 80s even though it was a big
successes would be you know big
mainstream movie and stuff like that
which a lot of horror fans are kind of
don't like but actually this has I think
this has like some really creepy scenes
and it's really effective like the
characters are very likable and
relatable you actually care about what
happens to them even though it gets kind
of crazy like especially near the end
where she has to go through the [ __ ]
closet and ceiling and like the big
monster face comes out of the closet and
[ __ ] like that like it seems kind of
over the top but for some reason I think
it works and it works because the family
is so grounded in reality that when they
see this [ __ ] and they're like
disbelieving it you know you relate to
them so much that you're like yeah [ __ ]
man that's that's pretty scary
it was a movie of its time yeah I
remember seeing it in its time and and
liking it yeah because it did deliver
things that audience had not seen yet it
had really good special effects for the
time yeah so you're seeing something
you'd never seen before for the very
first time yeah Wow yeah I'm not buying
it but that sure was [ __ ] cool in
like I said the special effects still
look pretty decent yeah for today I'm
back in then they were almost all of the
worldly although I still I start to say
that I think I think ghostbusters one
was a better movie uh yeah I'd agree
with you on there because it offered a
little bit more
was more it was like a bigger it was in
a bigger scope it was taking place in a
whole city yeah yeah there's a bunch of
different characters they were joking
around some of them yeah their gods were
involved I thought was pretty cool we're
gonna have to do a review guys because
that one was definitely easily one of my
favorites too was okay it was okay it
was okay you could tell that they were
really trying to recreate Ghostbusters 1
but how are you how can you recreate
that they should've done something
totally different
now there's supposed to be a
Ghostbusters 3 coming out with the
original cast I heard it yeah I heard
about that and I and I saw a picture of
Bill Murray with the that could be done
right if the story is good and if it was
in and you could maybe to bring about a
retirement yeah hey man my wish was
Ann's my dream went you know my wish was
answered I wanted Arnold to come back in
to Conan he's doing it yeah Arnold's
coming back - dude - Conan I'm [ __ ]
ready man because he is so pumped
I hope it's King Conan and I hope it's
in the job Milius style of Conan one
where he's now it was supposed to be
melius wanted Conan 3 to be how the
moral of the story was how to remain
relevant as a warrior in your old age
yeah and that's really what that's what
that's what Arnold needs to be doing how
do you remain well relevant he's been
doing a good job he's been in movies
lately I think but if you were an old
warrior how do you remain relevant
that's well that's supposedly it's gonna
be called hopefully it's called King
Conan that was that was the proposed
title going back years they've been
thinking about this move for years yeah
it might be something it might be Conan
the Conqueror I hope not I hope it's
just King Conan even though that sounds
a lot like King Kong so they might not
do that mostly but yeah so like I said
if you haven't seen poltergeist you know
come on what where have you been what
have you been doing yeah all this time
you got to see this one
you really do it's it seems like I mean
particularly if you're if you're gonna
do any kind of sweep of like a like the
80s horror
you gotta see you the highlights of all
the 80s you got to see this one yes it's
a mainstream film
yes it's very Spielberg Ian but that's
what it's true I think it's one of its
strong points yeah like I said it's you
know it is what it is everybody it
actually has some really great creepy
like iconic scenes in it yeah and um you
know it's so much a part of the cultural
framework you know from [ __ ] you know
you only move the head so they're just
like there's so many like references to
this yeah like in other media right that
you really need to see this
yeah and if you're a young listener and
you've seen you know the new bumblebee
and you like that you'd like this too
it's yeah you know it's not transformers
it's ghosts you know but it's that same
tone ghost that same vibe kid eating
trees yeah corpses it's pretty cool yeah
so yeah check it out if you haven't
already and you know if you have checked
it it's good go watch it in that's good
to see it again if you like it as much
as you worked it back in the 80s cuz
that's certainly yeah it's time capsule
you know it takes you back to another
era and you go yeah I remember it was as
cool as I remember it look at that kids
Star Wars toys yeah look at and
Carolyn's headboard like the wicker
or whatever the hell that was like that
wicker yeah white pearly thing I had one
like that another one another one that
took me back
Robocop one yeah seeing Robocop one I
was oh man I remember when a badass
apartment look that way it's funny okay
it is funny how much of how much of my
childhood like I remember in movies is
like we had that couch yeah yeah yeah I
remember a lot of the furniture for more
than the clothes and [ __ ] even all right
so we've done decor yeah so that'll do
it for our latest movie retrospective
remember if you liked the show
like share subscribe on all your social
media if you'd like to financially
support the show you can go to our
patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
and in the sidebar there's a little
button that says you can go to paypal
and make a donation so you can do that
if you would like to do that instead and
remember that our regular episodes come
out every Tuesday these here movie
retrospectives come out every Friday and
13 o'clock matinee which is three new
movies in the theater comes out every
Sunday we will see you next time bye